من خلف تماما هذه الاعمده الدخان هي في
مدينه بحري وفي المنطقه الصناعيه الصناعيه
ذات الحريقين الذين تحدثت عنهما انه
الكاميرا لا ادري اذا كان هذا متاحا سالم
هل تستطيع
تحريك الكاميرا ممكن تماما بكل تاكيد هذه
المنطقه هي مدينه بحري التي اندلع فيها
الحريق في هذه المنطقه بالتحديد والان في
هذه اللحظات وفي هذه الاثناء نستمع الى
اصوات مدافع كذلك في الجهه الشرقيه كذلك
وهي جهه مطار الخرطوم هذه المنطقه منطقه
بحري اندلع في حريقين في السوق المركزي في
مدينه بحري او عفوا في المنطقه الصناعيه
في بحري اندلع هذين الحريقين ولم يعلم ما
هي الاسباب لهذين الحريقين حتى الان مررنا
بالقرب منهما وجدنا اعداد من المواطنين
وليس ببعيد منهما ارتكازات لقوات الدعم
السريع موجوده في تلك المنطقه هذه المناطق
تنتشر فيها قوات الدعم السريعه على
الشوارع وايضا هل تم قصف هذه المناطق
بالطائرات ما المعلومات لديكم حول هذا
الامر خصوصا اننا دخلنا في تمديد للهدنه
هل هناك اي تحليق للطائرات بعد اعلان
الدخول في الهدنه الثانيه
تحليق الطائرات كان صباح اليوم كانت
الطائرات قليلا في بدايه هذا اليوم كان
هناك تحليق لبعض الطائرات ثم بدا هذا
الامر في التلاشي حتى هذه اللحظه توقف
تحليق الطائرات في فوق السماء الخرطوم لكن
الجيش السوداني ظل يقول انه ملتزم بهذه
الهدنه وان الدعم السريع هو من يخترق هذه
الهدنه وهناك تبادل للاتهامات في هذا
الامر فيما يتعلق الالتزام بهذه الهدنه
على الارض لم نشهد الى هذه اللحظه هدنه
كامله بعدم اطلاق النار او الالتزام
الكامل بهذا المبدا مبدا عدم اطلاق النار
ولا يسمع المواطن ولا طلقه واحده منذ
بدايه هذه الاشتباكات وحتى الان اين تتركز
الاشتباكات خصوصا خلال الساعات الاخيره
كان هناك انباء بانه في محيط القصر
الرئاسي وايضا حول المطار وايضا مقر
القياده بشكل محدود الى اي مدى هذه
الانباء دقيقه
نعم هذا صحيح لكن يضاف اليه الاشتباكات
التي هي موجوده في مدينه ام درمان في محيط
الاذاعه والتلفزيون سمعت ايضا اصوات
للذخيره والمدافع الثقيله والخفيفه كذلك
في الجهه الجنوبيه من ام درمان منطقه
صالحه ايضا تشهد كذلك اشتباكات وسماع
لدويه اطلاق النار وكذلك المدافع الثقيله
والخفيفه لكن
بامكانيه بحي اذا كان بامكانك سالم ان
تبقى معنا بالاتصال بالصوت وان تخرج من
الكادر قليلا كي تتيح للمصور ان يعطينا
صوره
ابرز واشمل لمشهد الخرطوم
نعم يمكن
يمكن يمكن ذلك بالنظر الى هذه المناطق
التي ذكرتها الان بالمجمل مدينه بحري هي
الاقل الان في الاشتباكات وفي تجدد
الاشتباكات خلال هذا اليوم مدينه بحري
ربما تشهد هدوءا نسبيا قليلا عكس ما يدور
في
الخرطوم وكذلك في ام درمان طيب الان فيما
يتعلق بحركه النزوح ذكرت بان هناك حركه
نزوح تتزامن مع دخولنا الاسبوع الثاني من
هذه الاشتباكات الى اين تتركز داخليا
وايضا حجم وتقديرات اعداد من تركوا
الخرطوم بسبب هذه الاشتباكات
نعم بالنسبه لعمليه النزوح عمليه النزوح
في الغالب هي تتركز في اطراف الخرطوم
واندرمان وبحري في كل واحده منهما هنالك
منفذ يخرج الى واحده من الولايات لكن
بالمجمل هذه حركه النزوح مستمره الى
الولايات المجاوره لولايه الخرطوم اذا
تحدثنا عن ولايه الجزيره هنا شرقا او
الجنوب الشرقي وكذلك شمالا في منطقه
الولايه الشماليه ونهر النيل كذلك هذه
الولايات المتاخمه لولايه الخرطوم
والقريبه منها شهدت عمليات نزوح عاليه جدا
وواضحه يضاف اليها مساله النزوح الى دول
مجاوره كاثيوبيا مثلا او دوله مصر كذلك
ايضا شهدت حركه نزوح وحرص من المواطنين
للخروج من هذه المناطق التي تشكل خطرا على
حياتهم تحدثت عن وجود عدد كبير من
ارتكازات في الخرطوم هل رصدتم ربما او
حددتم ايهما يتمتع
بارتكازات اكثر سواء كان الجيش او الدعم
السريع
في المناطق التي تحدثنا عنها وهي المناطق
القريبه من الخرطوم وبحري هذه المناطق
القريبه من المناطق المركزيه اي من مركز
المدينه هذه المناطق تنتشر فيها بكثافه
قوات الدعم السريع وتقوم بعمليات تمشيط
ولديها ارتكازات عاليه الجيش السودانيه
تمركز في المناطق المحيطه بقياداته
والمناطق العسكريه التابعه للجيش السوداني
يتمركز فيها قوات الجيش السوداني وايضا
تحكم سيطرتها عليها وتحرص على وضع
ارتكازات في هذه المناطق يصعب فعلا الحديث
عن هذا الموضوع بدقه لكن المعرض في الشارع
يجد هذين الارتكازين وفي كل الاحوال كل
هذه الامور تنبي بان هنالك ذعرا وخوفا لدى
المواطن من هذه التحرك العسكري ووجود هذه
الاسلحه بكثافه في الشارع بهذه الطريقه
لان الارتكازات يحمل فيها الجنود العديد
من انواع الاسلحه مما يجعل المواطنين في
ذعر مستمر خاصه ان احيانا في الشارع
الواحد تجد اربعه او خمسه ارتكازات بهذه
القوات خاصه
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات